it's been some time now well october
since we last saw the queen in person
and i think
certainly people are are still concerned
about the queen's health we didn't see
her over the christmas go to church we
only saw her in that christmas day
broadcast and um i think
courtiers are very weary not to
overwhelm the queen with with
appointments or to to tie her up too
much with a busy schedule um my my
understanding is that the moment really
is just about carrying out light dust
work at windsor
more virtual audiences and meetings and
really making sure that the queen is
in
tip-top health um ahead of her june
jubilee celebrations which for the queen
and for the royal family are very much
the focal of 2022. the plans for the
2022 jubilee celebrations are absolutely
going ahead and overcoming weeks we hope
to be learning more details um about
this four day event but the focus is on
on the queen on the queen being you know
well and absolutely able to take part in
those celebrations i certainly think
we're going to see kobe permitting more
travel being undertaken and the royals
representing the queen both here in the
united kingdom and overseas no monarch
has ever celebrated a platinum jubilee
this is an incredibly important event
and and one that the queen is very keen
to celebrate she's very much looking
forward to the jubilee celebrations um
but there are you know there are some
hurdles to get past before we get to
those celebrations
[Music]